okay today I'm going to talk to you
about immune response so what an immune
response is is how our body responds
when a pathogen enters the body how do
we how does our body react to try and
get rid of this pathogen so first of all
let's imagine this we have a pathogen
entering the body now what a pathogen is
is this is a microorganism so a tiny
living thing that can cause you harm
such as a bio virus or a bacterium now
on the surface of the pathogen we have
particular a kind of particular protein
on the surface and this protein is
called an antigen now we've got a nice
way of remembering this because the
antigen goes on the surface of the
puffit gern now this enters the body and
it starts to reproduce now we want to
get rid of this everybody wants to get
rid of this pathogen because it could
make yourself so in our bodies we have a
type of white blood cell that is called
it's got a fancy name it's called a B
lymphocyte a B lymphocyte so what this B
lymphocyte does is it recognizes this
antigen and it's and it kind of it
recognizes that this is not a part of
our body this is something foreign so
what it does is it produces these things
called an T bodies some antibodies now
these have a complementary shape to
those the antigen on the surface of the
pathogen now a lot of people get
antibodies and antigens confused the way
I remember it is that antigen goes on
the pathogen and antibodies are produced
by cells in our body so that's the way I
hope to remember it so what happens is
after these antibodies are made they
could be released and they can attack
the pathogen by attaching to the antigen
on the surface so that's a basic immune
response
now these antibodies are specific to the
shape of this
tgd for example let's say we had a
different pathogen answering each
pathogen will have a different antigen
so a different structure on the surface
now these antibodies from this B
lymphocyte here would not be able to fit
on to the antigen of this one it's not
the right shape so we'd need a different
B lymphocyte to make different
antibodies for a different pathogen now
the last thing we need to know about
this are these things called memory
cells because after we've had this
pathogen and wait for them after we've
had this pathogen enter the body some of
these white blood cells remain in the
blood some of these B lymphocytes remain
in the blood and they now refer to as
memory cells because what they do is
they already have this particular
antibody which is specific for this
particular pathogen so if this
particular pathogen was to come back on
memory cells in the blood can rapidly
release these antibodies which can break
down these pathogens really really
quickly so that secondary immune
response is much bigger and is much
faster than the primary one there's
another video about vaccinations that
goes into this in more detail
so just to recap pathogens as a
scientific term for a microorganism
which can cause you harm on the surface
of the pathogen there is an antigen this
is just a protein structure this is the
thing that our white blood cells called
B lymphocytes recognize they produce
antibodies which are complementary to
the shape of the antigen the antibodies
kind of bind to the to the antigen and
breaks them down and once once that
pathogens been destroyed we have memory
cells which stay in the blood which can
which already have this antibody
produced and could release it rapidly if
the pathogen was to come back thank you